so as some of you already know I really
enjoy eating a good avocado which
despite its appearance that it looks
like a vegetable but it's actually a
fruit and let's say that I eat two
avocados per day and I eat two avocados
per day for six days now there's a
couple of ways that I can think about
how many avocados did I eat I could say
hey I eat 2 a day and I'm going to do
that for six days so I'm gonna add six
twos together so that'll be 2 plus 2
plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 I have six
twos right over there and then I can add
them together and we could say 2 plus 2
is 4 you add another 2 you get 2 6 you
add another 2 you get 2 8 yet another do
to get to 10 yet another 2 you get to 12
and that all is fine
but there's an easier way to express
this repeated addition one way is to
view it as multiplication instead of
just writing out six twos and adding
them together mathematicians have come
up with a neater way of writing that
let's say okay we're going to add up a
bunch of two's how many twos are we
going to add up we're going to have six
of those twos and we need to come up
with some type of a symbol for it so we
will use this X looking thing and so six
times two can be viewed as repeated
addition in exactly this same way so 6
times 2 would be equal to 12 and we
could go the other way around if someone
were to ask you what is 4 times 3 pause
this video and see if you can write it
out as repeated addition like we saw up
here well one way to interpret this is
to say this is 4 threes so we could say
this is equal to 3 plus 3 plus 3 plus 3
and 3 plus 3 is 6 6 plus 3 is 9 9 plus 3
is equal to 12 you might be familiar
skip counting and you would say 3 6 9 12
just out of curiosity what do you think
3 times 4 is going to be pauses
and try to represent it as repeated in
addition and then see what you come up
with well we can interpret this as three
fours and so we could say this is going
to be 4 plus 4 plus 4 and if we skip
count fours we'd have 4 8 12 I was about
to go to 16 4 8 12 so this is going to
be 12 so this is interesting at least
for this example for these two examples
I got to the same thing 4 times 3 got me
the same result as 3 times 4 interesting
I wonder if that's always true but
anyway big picture from this video is
that you can view multiplication as
repeated addition